America's economy is approaching a
critical Tipping Point we do need to
raise the debt ceiling to avoid economic
Calamity the U.S government has hit its
debt ceiling of 31.4 trillion dollars
causing a tense standoff
Congress has to vote to raise the debt
ceiling Republicans who control the
House of Representatives are using this
power as a bargaining chip to rewrite
the budget speaker McCarthy offered a
very different way forward he's proposed
deep cuts that I believe are going to
hurt American families I would hope that
he'd be willing to negotiate for the
next two weeks so we could actually
solve this problem and not take America
on the brink neither side wants to back
down but if they don't catastrophe looms
not lifting the debt ceiling would be a
Kamikaze act that would threaten the
health and viability of the American
economy with disastrous spillover
effects from the global economy
so what is the debt ceiling and why does
reaching it mean possible economic
disaster
the debt ceiling which is really
uniquely an American thing refers to the
total amount of money uh that the
government the federal government is
allowed to borrow it's a political
creation uh inevitably government debt
goes up over time the size of the
economy is getting bigger the government
is regularly running deficits so you
would expect that debt would go up over
time but because you have this
prescribed debt ceiling from time to
time the government's borrowing hits
that limit when that happens the thing
that has to occur is that the debt
ceiling has to be raised the point is
that America has incurred all of these
debts because of all of its ongoing
obligations whether to paying government
salaries or to paying retired pensioners
their Social Security payments to pay
for health insurance to paying for
ongoing government programs if they
don't increase the debt ceiling the
government will not be able to make the
spending obligations it would only be a
matter of time before the government
would very likely default on its debts
that would send shock waves through
Global markets it would fundamentally
undermine the position of the dollar
critics of the debt ceiling have
proposed workarounds there's two that
you mainly hear about one is the idea
that the treasury should mint an
absolutely massive coin uh not massive
in terms of size but massive in terms of
value perhaps a trillion dollar platinum
coin deposit that at the Federal Reserve
and then use that to fund government
operations the other workaround that
you'll hear about sometimes is using the
14th Amendment of the Constitution which
states that U.S government debts shall
not be questioned so the argument is
that the White House can cite that
Amendment while the basic solution to
the debt ceiling is for Congress to
agree that the debt ceiling is damaging
is harmful uh and and just basically
agree to suspend it in perpetuity that
would be the simplest solution but
politically it's just not tenable uh
because the party that's not in power
does enjoy the leverage that that the
debt ceiling confers upon them
foreign